sideline to work with boobs my Fox was
all over him the boxer that over it's
excellent defense by Fox mother Stalin
later dad was there about cauley-stein
and another Atlanta turnover their
fourth be elites a script ray young
jumped with a wide open three good and
we're even it's well it's pretty amazing
here the guy who was a defensive coach
and now he comes with a team that likes
to push and run buddy hield for three
that's good throw it down for me big man
Willie obliged CBN Fox right here that
little extra dribble that he gave just
opens buddy here the basketball and
school the Hawks down in Frank business
well didn't take long for the Kings to
answer from downtown and that's him on
Shumpert not a lot of contested shots in
this first half no contest their box
line Shumpert the elites 'knows that
he's got time
box buddy oh that's incredible
what a play great signed by the Aaron
[ __ ] again he missed at eight seconds
left box King's breakout faculae badly
the flying duck by Marvin Bagley 69 64
73 young steals it but rather loses it
Kings steal it buddy a transition three
automatic and the Kings playing the new
NBA stop the elites ax wide open
nemanja be Alicia be healed took the
basket catching a nice load delivery no
basket it was on the Fox the rebound
that's his eight board body give the
hill from Marietta